the diver ceo live my live show my live
reincarnation of this podcast is coming
on tour and it's coming to a city near
you there's a link in the description
below put your email address in and i
will email you when tickets go on sale
can't wait to see
[Music]
they're learned from your swipes on
instagram your brain does what you tell
it to do you're the boss tell it ai is
going to be a billion times smarter than
humans i would take data points and
measurements and topics like happiness
gratitude is the ultimate solution to
the happiness equation mo gaudat he is
an expert on the topic of happiness if
everyone in the world listened to this
podcast episode the world would be a
drastically better place i was chief
business officer of google x through
that network i've connected with the
wisest people on the planet we have an
app coming out in christmas that is
aiming to get to the point where we know
exactly why you're unhappy
literally the simplest
surgical operation not known to
humankind but five mistakes happened and
four hours later ali was gone there's
nothing i can do to bring him back
but i can make his essence alive my
intention shifted from spending the rest
of my life in grief to actually writing
what he taught me so that i can share it
with the world
[Music]
you know i've done this podcast for the
last 12 months
every week
and there's one name which my guests the
people that sit in front of me the
successful athletes entrepreneurs
business people from all walks of life
and just generally ambitious successful
people kept saying and it was moe's name
you know i hype up these episodes a lot
but i've never said this
this was my favorite podcast of all
time
because of the lasting value that i know
it will have on my life i think i cried
twice in this podcast episode
who is moon he's a genius business
person so smart in fact that google made
him the head of google x which was their
special projects division where they do
the most crazy insane things from flying
cars to machine learning anything a
genius would be capable of doing he's
also a remarkable entrepreneur
but the thing that will bring the most
value to you in this episode if you
listen to it will be what he says about
happiness
and some of the things he says today
have just created these like personal
revelations in my head where i genuinely
feel that i have to go go and sit down
in a room alone and think about them for
the next couple of weeks genuinely
life-changing and you've never heard me
this enthusiastic on the podcast so if
you're ever gonna trust me with an
episode trust me on this one
are you ready
i hope you are without further ado i'm
stephen bartlett and this is the diver
ceo i hope nobody's listening but if you
are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
no
i guess my first question for you is um
because you know when i look at the the
things that you write about the topics
um you speak about so often the
businesses you've built the areas of
interest you have and i see that they're
so diverse and also they're very
smart shall i say oh thank you mike my
question is what were those um early
personal but also early professional
experiences that have shaped the way
you see and analyze the world
what is that context that we need to
know about you
uh
i i think the thing that maybe shapes me
most is that i was born in the east
raised in the east with the culture of
the east and educated in the west and
worked in the west with the culture of
the west
and um in a very unusual way i didn't
judge either i think there is so much
value to learn in each of them but
they're almost exact opposites and and
to be able to embrace both of them
maybe has allowed me to translate
concepts that are normally spoken about
on one more than the other
to the other so so most of my work
really is
highly dependent on my early
math
you know love of mathematics love of
physics i'm i'm a very serious geek i
don't say that in public because it
affects my uh
i just said that i affects my ceo job
but i'm really geeky like to the point
that i was writing code until a few
years ago but i take all of that
language of very being very organized
very systemic almost you know engineered
in everything and i try to explain
concepts like spirituality like love
like humanity humanity's position in the
modern age and so on and so forth and i
and i explain them in slightly unusual
ways you know i use for example quantum
physics and theory of relativity to try
and explain death um i use mathematics
and theory of probability to co to to
discuss the question of the presence of
a divine being and so on and so forth
and i think the thing is i have a brain
defect somewhere that basically does not
stop me from addressing
crazy ideas so i i normally i'm writing
six books at the same time
and
and
and i love it i love it i don't write
for for you sadly i i hate to say this i
write for me so i get inspired by a
topic and then i build a structure
literally like we write subroutines in
software i write the entire you know
flow chart if you want of the book and
then leave it on my desktop and then
start to work on it sometimes for a year
sometimes for two years and and
eventually something comes out that
informs me and enriches me and at the
same time it you know interests people
you write for you
oh absolutely so why did you write a
book about happiness that's the most
selfish thing i've ever done in my life
i mean if you if you know
uh my story was um so i i was very
successful at a very young age so
unusual i mean i'm born and raised in
egypt educated in public school public
university in egypt
so my biggest dream was i was going to
become sales manager in ibm egypt that
was my biggest dream
and look at what happened i mean i i
went through
beyond my wildest expectations
chief business officer of google x is
literally the second best job on the
planet okay and and and you know i
i uh
i had all of this
you know that people dream of at a very
young age at 29 i had uh you know the
big villa with the swimming pool uh
you know all of the money all of the
suits all of the luxury cars uh from 25
when i had nothing to 29 when i had
everything i had the most wonderful
woman in my life beautiful wise
sensitive loving who gave me two
wonderful kids and i was clinically
depressed
and and and it's not an unusual story
where where we keep chasing all of those
things i mean my my luck was that i hit
my middle age crisis at 29 when i
achieved everything they told me i was
supposed to achieve and couldn't find
happiness and so i ended up in a place
where i started to research the topic uh
just like i would anything else
and i couldn't get a word i just
couldn't get it you know they told me to
meditate my engineering mind was like
tell me why explain something to me tell
me why it works right
you know if they told me to say um i
would get really angry i still don't say
um right but but the idea is
uh is my brain wouldn't get it and
instead of me
rejecting that i started to look at
those topics as an engineer so i would
start to do literally you know like the
scientific method i would i would take
data points and and measurements and try
to do fitting lines and curves and
charts on topics like happiness
and
you know it started to work for me so
four years and i started to really
become a little better and i would go
back to my wonderful son ali
who was born a tiny little zen monk he
knew those things instinctively and even
as a young child you know age eight i
think was when i started to discuss
those things with him he would listen
there and ask me a couple of questions
clearly to entertain me and then
basically say well done papa this is
amazing you could have just asked me
okay and then he would literally explain
it to me from the heart so how the heart
feels it i i would get how the left
brain sees it and he would get how the
heart feels it your son at eight he was
so wise even he was so wise ali when he
was 16
i promise you my friends will tell you i
would actually i i publicly announced
when i grow older i want to be like ali
he was a very unusual being and and he
uh he he spoke very little
very very very little he was either
laughing all the time and being silly
and goofy
or when you asked him a serious question
he would stay silent and then speak
eight words okay and those eight words
would literally reshape your world okay
and i noticed that at a very young age
for him and so i started to consult with
him on a lot of topics uh on a lot of
topics and on happiness specifically
together we ended up with a model that
worked
you know we had the happiness equation
we had the happiness model
and it worked and it worked so well that
when we lost him sadly
when he was 21
my intention shifted from spending the
rest of my life in grief
to actually writing what he taught me so
that i can share it with the world and
that basically determined the next life
for me after the life of the executive
and the chief business officer and the
you know stock options and the luxury
and the cars that second life really was
the result of his departure
and during during that period the
inspiration that inspired you to write
the book at the very beginning and go on
that journey to really find the answer
to happiness you said you were
clinically depressed yes now for people
that don't know what that means
practically can you give a description
nothing would make me happy and you can
you can literally
you know as i so i i interviewed ruby
wax on my on my podcast on slo-mo and
ruby was known for her sometimes you
know depression and sometimes teaching
and she would describe it as they cut
your head off and fill you with concrete
when you're depressed you're unable to
do anything you're unable to enjoy
anything you're unable to engage right
and it comes in in different layers but
but for me the the challenge was
i was
so successful i was so successful i
literally could print money on demand i
mean there were times when my
my wife would say can we change the car
and i would say so what would you like
and she would say this and i would say
okay wait until wednesday and i would be
on the stock market uh you know trading
for a few days and making money right it
was it was so crazy because of my math
skills before the age of machine trading
was really as as entrenched as as it is
today i could make money on demand and
yet i poured that money on my life and i
couldn't find happiness okay i you know
and and that really shakes you because
now you can get the vacations they're
talking about you can wear what their
they told you is going to make you happy
you can buy the things that they told
you are is going to make you happy but
nothing's making you happy and then it
started to reflect on my family and i
remember vividly the turning point was a
saturday morning when you know my my
daughter ali my son was that little zen
monk
my daughter is life her life itself she
truly is pure joy okay and she was you
know it was a saturday morning she's
jumping up and down in joy saying ah
mommy said we're gonna go there can we
stop and get you know ice cream on the
way can we do that she's so happy and i
was doing whatever busy people do
reading an email or whatever crap and
and basically i looked at her slowly
raising my head in grumpiness and said
can we please be serious for a minute
okay what's serious she was five and i
could see with my own eyes as my
daughter's beautiful daughter's heart
broke
okay and i think to me that was
basically the moment where i said i
can't live with this person anymore i
can't live with me
and when when you see that you make that
choice and sadly most people who are
successful like your audiences
actually
wait until that moment happens when when
they're old when they've gone to the
point where
the good days have passed the days where
you could have actually built that
connection with your family or or with
you know enjoyed your life a little more
are behind you and then they wake up i
was so lucky that i woke up when i was
29.
so you have this idea as you say there
to write this book and to answer this
question that has become so relevant and
important to answer in your life and as
you're on that journey and and
consulting with you with ali
ali passes yes
no so ali ali left after he trained me
well enough so uh
uh it's really interesting i mean he he
um
so i i started my research maybe when he
was six or yeah he was six seven
uh and finished when he was 18 19 and
you couldn't dent my happiness then i
was
i was the example of happiness i mean
i'm a middle eastern and at the time i
used to work at microsoft at least
through that journey i used to work at
microsoft and microsoft's office was in
seattle so i would fly
every month for a week to seattle
from dubai to jfk and then from jfk to
washington and every time i landed in
jfk i got that random security check
where they give me a red envelope and
take me to homeland security was really
not the kindest of treatment if you want
with a stupid smile on my face like i
flew 12 hours then i start stood in line
for an hour and a bit and then they gave
me that envelope and there is a guard
walking next to me now assuming i'm a
criminal until proven otherwise and they
sit me in that room and i have that
stupid smile on my face nothing could
dent my happiness okay i have beautiful
thoughts inside me i have compassion for
every one of those officers you know
that they're just doing their job and of
course they're worried about their
country and it's really weird and to the
point that i did this 37 times in a row
okay and to the point that i would walk
into the homeland security office and
the officers behind the counter would go
like mr gates is back okay they know i'm
the guy from microsoft i've been there
last month i would walk to the counter
and they say answer the same 10
questions you uh we asked you last time
so i would say this is my name this is
my mother's name right and go through
them one by one without a dent in my
happiness
but then life tests you
so so
uh and and by the way i mean
we can talk about this but of course i
you can feel unhappy but i found a way
to always come back to happiness if you
want
um
and then life tests you and i think a
life nudges you it it seems that's all
for happy needed to be written okay and
i had the notes for it in 2011 but hey
chief business officer of google x busy
busy busy busy and i kept delaying it
and delaying it and delaying it until
ali basically came to visit us in in
dubai
2014 and he was
diagnosed with a very simple
appendix inflammation
and yeah you know it's literally the
simplest
surgical operation not known to
humankind it's literally a four or five
minute thing
but
five mistakes happened five in a row
every one is every one of them was
preventable every one of them was
fixable but five in a row fixed wrong
and four hours later ali was gone
yeah i mean
it's easy to understand how it feels
even today seven years later losing a
child is
is just the hardest thing ever uh at
least for me it's the hardest thing ever
like if life had taken all my money and
all what i've achieved and you know made
me homeless it would have probably felt
less painful than losing him
but but uh but
our reaction was very very unusual
instead of
trying to
you know
fight with life
uh i simply said okay you know he's gone
there's nothing i can do to bring him
back but i can make his essence alive i
can keep his essence in this world
and his essence to me was what he taught
me he saved my life with what he taught
me about happiness
and so i sat down to write first time
that i really write in english as my
english is not my first language
i wrote for four and a half months
straight
and you know if you've read the
alchemist by paulo coelho you know when
you when you know your life's purpose
the universe conspires to make it happen
i just can't tell you what happened
since then i mean
every part of the universe is just
pushing for this mission to work you
know from
finding my agent at the time where he
was actually not feeling great about his
life so he kept saying can you send me
another chapter can you send me another
chapter until i sent the whole book
saying what's he going to do with this
and then literally we meet and he
basically says can i please represent
you
we go out meet 17 publishers within a
week in the in in new york in the in the
capital of publishing and then things
roll and roll and roll to the point that
i came here in the uk uh after literally
a week after the the publication of soul
for happy and i had that interview very
famous with channel 4 news
which within three days was the highest
watched news clip on the history of
channel 4 to the point that the ceo is
starting to wonder like i've been bought
broadcasting violence and war for the
you know last i don't know how many
years and my highest watched clip at the
time it was 37 million views is about
happiness okay which obviously is
understandable it is the pandemic of our
time
within three days after that we were
watched 87 million times okay
more than double the highest uh and and
the more the movement was starting the
one billion happy movement was starting
basically i think it was a very strong
confirmation to the world that this is
something the world needs
and you can actually feel today that
there is a shift not because of me only
but because there are so many people
coming into this
there is a big shift now between
employee satisfaction and employee
happiness between you know let's just
work on mental health and actually let's
work on happiness and so on and so forth
there's seen it seems that the world is
getting it that that you know we're not
supposed to be grinding ourself
and giving away our lives
for things that we think are going to
make us happy we might as well be happy
and get everything as a result because
we can then be successful we can be
engaged we can be lovable we can be you
know supported and so on and so forth
it's just remarkable in my mind that
you can lose the most important thing to
you as you've described it in your life
your son
to human error
and still not fall into
resentment or bitterness or what would
it do regret
what would it do i mean of course i mean
i mean i took steps to make sure that
things are corrected so that no one else
gets hurt right uh but what would it do
i mean i was very prominent at the time
when ali died
i was chief business officer of google x
but i was still between dubai and
california so i spent half of my time in
dubai and i it was after seven years of
being vice president of emerging markets
for google so i had opened half of
google's offices globally i was very you
know well connected to the business
leaders and government leaders in dubai
and so when ali died we got a call from
the top of the ministry of health saying
we heard what happened i'm so sorry mao
would you mind if we perform an autopsy
on ali's body to get to the top to the
bottom of this
so i looked at his mother sitting next
to me most wonderful woman on the planet
with her eyes teary and i said nibel
would you mind if they do that
and she raised his head and said would
it bring ali back
and that one sentence anchored us in the
truth okay you see the problem with the
grief is that the cycle of grief takes
you five steps and the very last step is
acceptance
okay and that step of acceptance could
take you
70 years sometimes
for us
the truth was glaringly obvious four
hours later there's nothing you can do
to bring him back this is it and and the
finality of death is so corrective of
all of our human illusions
this is it he's not coming back so what
can you do now and my brain started to
attack me my brain started to say you
should have you know the one thought for
the first
few days was you should have driven him
to another hospital you should have
driven him until i said to my to my to
my brain like okay i i wish i could go
back and drive him to another hospital i
can't so can you please bring me a
thought i can act upon
okay and so i had a couple of days of
silence and then
then my wonderful daughter comes to me
they were very very close and she said
papa ali
uh had a dream a couple of weeks ago and
he called and told me about it
and i think it's very irrelevant you
need to know okay and i said what baby
and he said and she said he dreamt he
was everywhere and part of everyone
and that he it felt so amazing that he
didn't want to be back in his body
and when she told me i still tear up
thinking about it today when she told me
this my blurry brain
could only listen to this is my master
giving me my target that's the only
thing i heard it's like make me
everywhere and part of everyone that's
what i heard
and at the time i was head of google i i
understood billions i knew how to get
the message to billions of people so
what did i do i literally said out loud
consider it done
it's done okay and i told you when i
wrote soul for happy it was the most
selfish thing you can ever do i wanted
the essence of my son to to to live on
and so
i basically wrote it with the intention
of okay i'm gonna make him everywhere
and part of everyone i'm just gonna
spread this beautiful essence to 10
million people
and then
i don't know 70 years later through six
degrees of separation a tiny bit of him
will be everywhere and part of everyone
that was my blurry brain but maybe it
was also life's way of saying
share something do something useful
enough
enough building phones and building you
know faster
engines and you know maybe the world
needs something different maybe maybe
share something that actually is needed
by humanity
is that where that 10 billion million
number came from 10 million was the
original target yeah 10 million happy
was at the time it felt crazy that we
were shooting for 10 million but again
with things like channel 4 alone
i think by week 8 we had reached 137
million people right okay but we don't
measure those by the way we don't
measure just the views we we measure
how many people
took action
uh in terms of
of receiving the message so it's it's
basically one billion happy today's
three steps step one is we're going to
give you send you a message that wakes
you up that tells you happiness is your
birthright and it's highly attainable it
follows an equation okay so you can
actually
do certain things and you will be
happier right the second once you you
get that message that's not enough
we we count you as one of billion happy
if you take one of two actions
afterwards either you invest in your own
happy happiness right so you invest in
your own happiness by going to another
piece of content shifting to you know
read a book or watch another video we
can see that you're investing in your
happiness asking me a question getting
in touch whatever that is or you share
happiness forward okay and the entire
ponzi scheme if you want of one billion
happy is built on the idea of
we hope that as a small team uh
within hopefully the next 10 12 years uh
we will have
you know cultivated a million champions
that will make a billion people happy as
their own
mission and then we will get completely
forgotten okay because it's the only way
for it to succeed is that it's not
counting on you know one person or one
face or one team because the team will
get dismantled and i'm you know going to
disappear and it has to be a movement
right and so the whole movement is on
that pillar number three pillar number
three is you got a message of happiness
you you know it might have touched you
can you share it to two people and ask
them to share it to two people and ask
them to share it to two people simple
exponential curve simple ponzi scheme
really a positive ponzi scheme okay and
it's been working we think we're at 51
million which is not the biggest number
but you know you understand the the law
of accelerating returns right so if it's
now you know if we can do this again in
four years and then that becomes 100
million and then the 100 becomes 200 and
so on you know who knows who knows we
may get there
and the mission is i guess the banner of
the mission is self happy right is that
no no no no no no no actually not at all
so
books don't go to millions that's the
truth of books okay the books allow me
the opportunity to sit with you and
spread this to your audience okay uh but
but the mission is much bigger now so
the pillars of the mission are there is
a tremendous amount of content uh that i
put out there i mean if you search for
my name on google you'll have
hundreds of hours of videos i'm tireless
i did yeah
i watched several hours yeah and and
some of them are you know stamford
university classrooms and some some of
them are short conversations with you
know insightful people like yourself and
it's it's you know it's
there is hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of content of hours of content
but that's one side the other side of
course is uh
through that network i've of course
connected with the the wisest people on
the planet uh so you know when i was
chief business officer of google i would
be connected to prime ministers and
business owner or owners now i'm
connected to his holiness the dalai lama
the top monks in the world the top
teachers in the world and so i brought
all of them together on my on my podcast
on slo-mo and slo-mo is a very unusual
because it comes from a chief business
officer right
basically a simple message to say take a
little bit of time to slow down and
reflect okay and it's not me talking
it's the wisest people on the planet
like i get blown away every time okay
and and and so that's that's another
element the other element of course is
training material so we're working on
that we have an app coming out in
christmas that is actually really
promising so
we're building an artificial
intelligence based happiness assistant
which covers a very interesting gap that
we're all unhappy but we're not all
unhappy for the same reasons and so if i
this is dispatch content at you that is
irrelevant okay i'm probably gonna piss
you off rather than make you happy so
the app in version one it's not perfect
yet but in version two we're aiming to
to get to the point where we know
exactly why you're unhappy and so we're
able to actually show you the enough
learning and enough practice
that can allow you to find the path back
to happiness so it's more intelligent if
you want not in in
understanding happiness but in
understanding unhappiness if you want so
to understand what happiness is you have
to understand the cause of it yes and
you write about that extensively and
solve for happy
so what is the cause of unhappiness as
you see especially if you're building
sort of machine learning applications
that are going to
you know
solve you know make people arrive at
contentment or happiness in a
personalized way we must be able to know
what's causing this lack of
allow me a bit of time to explain it
because it it's simple when we get it
but it's not simple to get to it so so
happiness is very predictable okay if
you look back at any point in your life
where you ever felt happy there is one
commonality across all of those moments
that can actually be documented in a
mathematical equation okay
you've never felt happy
because of a specific event in your life
okay
take for example rain
rain doesn't make you happy or unhappy
there is no inherent value of happiness
in rain okay
rain makes you happy when you want to
alter your plants and it makes you
unhappy when you want to sunbathe right
and so it's not just the event rain it's
the comparison between the event
and an expectation in your mind of how
life should be okay if you're worried
about your plans then life should be
generous to me and get me rain so i can
water the plants and if life does that
then life meets your expectations and
you're happy okay and so happiness in
that sense becomes equal to or greater
than so it's really mathematics that
your perception of the events of your
life minus your expectations of how life
should be
okay and apply that to anything apply
that to anything so you know my favorite
example is nature
we're all happy in nature why are we all
happy in nature i mean you go out there
and there are ants and there are flies
and you know trees are crooked and there
are you know shrubs everywhere and
bushes and it's just really not that
hedged and organized but that's what we
expect
so you know nature's
chaos is what we expect nature to be and
so we feel happy you know nobody ever
sits in front of the ocean and says i
like the view but please mute the sound
okay you just take it you know it's it's
the monotonous sound and the view and
the wind and and the sun and the whole
experience right
and because of that
happiness becomes
very different than what was defined to
us
okay what was defined to us is that
happiness is found in a
gathering at the pub or a party or a you
know an activity or some kind of
pleasure or fun or elation or whatever
that is that's not at all true these i
call these the state of escape okay
happiness as per the definition of the
happiness equation is events equal to or
beating expectations life going my way
okay and so basically happiness is that
calm and peacefulness you feel
when you're okay with life as it is
it doesn't really matter what life is
okay what matters is that you can be
okay with it
right so so you take you know the
any example if your boss is annoying
and your expectation is yeah bosses are
annoying this is what life is about they
become bosses because they're annoying
right and and so if if that's your
expectation you're gonna look at it and
go like yeah i need to learn the skill
of managing annoying bosses okay and if
that's the case then you're not going to
be upset about it
similarly anything else if you look at
it then it's not just the event
it's your perception of the event so you
have
something to influence it's not just the
event your partner might say something
hurtful on friday at 4 p.m
that's the event my partner said
something hurtful at sunday morning you
tell yourself he or she doesn't love me
anymore okay that's your perception of
the event that's not actually the event
the event is something hurtful was said
but your perception of the event is your
work is your it's your brain adding
color to it and then you compare that to
your expectations right you compared my
boss is annoying too my boss shouldn't
be annoying where did you get that from
right so we blur the happiness equation
we break the happiness equation because
of what i call the six and seven
okay six grand illusions and seven blind
spots which are the six grand illusions
are basically
uh call them pathways
uh that the modern world teaches us to
navigate the modern world that our
illusions are not true okay
take for example control
everyone knows that to succeed in the
modern world you have to learn to
control certain events right
so you start to believe that the way to
succeed in life is to control everything
but the truth is even if you go down to
the basics of physics that we never are
in control
that the absolute design
of nature itself of the universe itself
is entropy and chaos right that's the
actual design and so if you try to
control it you're bound to be
disappointed a lot of events are going
to miss your expectations okay and yes
i'm not saying don't control anything at
all but start to understand that you're
you're going to be selective because you
have a finite amount of effort and by
the way even if you're selective and you
you try to control everything sometimes
things will fall out of control okay and
that should be your expectation once you
get that right that was one that was my
biggest illusion okay i'm a
mathematician i'm a software developer i
am a a physicist i am an engineer and i
am a senior executive it doesn't get
worse than that okay i'm like the worst
absolute the worst i used to give my
wonderful wife i swear to you stephen
don't judge me i used to give her a
spreadsheet that would tell her when to
wash the colors and when to wash the
whites based on our average consumption
and as a family to save the environment
and poor nibel would would actually
smile at me and say sure baby i will use
this
of course and ignores the hell out of me
because that's how crazy you can be when
it comes to control now these are the
illusions if you live your life through
the illusion of control good luck
finding happiness so six grand illusions
the illusion of uh of thought the
erosion or the illusion of self the
illusion of knowledge the illusion of
time control and fear okay now
that's one side and that disrupts your
your entire view of what to expect from
life because you're expecting
life to behave through a length of a
lens of an illusion the other side of it
is what i call seven blind spots okay
and the seven blind spots are not
really defects in your brain as a matter
of fact they are the very design of your
brain okay your brain is designed to
tell you what's wrong
okay it's not designed to you know if a
tiger shows up right here now my brain
has no
use whatsoever in telling me oh my god
look how majestic that animal is right
yeah it's a beautiful animal but my
brain will say we're gonna die
okay and we're gonna die is the idea
that basically makes our
uh uh our brain constantly look for
what's wrong blur the events of life huh
you ask a mother
and and she will say oh my daughter's
been sick all winter
you know she just had two episodes of
flu three days each but to the to the
caring heart of a mother that needs to
be exaggerated to the exaggeration is
one of the blind spots
your brain is trying to get you to take
action so it pushes you
it pushes you by exaggerating the event
a little bit so that you jump in and
take action and accordingly the event
you're comparing to you're comparing the
wrong event to the wrong expectation and
the happiness equation falls apart
under all of this you're inferring
something which i think will annoy a lot
of people and that is that happiness is
a choice
and that you you can choose to be happy
and that if you're unhappy and really
for many circumstances in our life day
to day and work and love in
relationships
personal responsibility is the
is the answer and entirely on you and a
lack thereof is the cause absolutely you
know what you just did
you've just lost us 88 of the audience i
know do you know why i know because i
did a tweet one day about this and
what my tweet was um
there's like i guess a mental model but
there's a refraining that can i think
has brought me happiness which is when
something happens to me i i used to like
many people say
x thing that happened has pissed me off
yeah and just by changing that sentence
to i've pissed myself off because of x3
absolutely and i tweeted that and i was
like try it just like reframe it and
take personal responsibility for how
you're feeling and in the comments
section everyone was like
nope yep people don't like the idea that
they have control over their emotional
responses so when i wrote so when i
wrote when i write books in general i
write them i write them like software so
i issue a beta version okay and i get
270 people i don't know why
it's fascinating yeah i get 270 people
to read it
on google docs so i give them editor
privileges so they i can actually edit
the text right and then something
fascinating happens they they edit the
text and then others edit what they
edited okay and there is a conversation
happening and basically it takes the
book to its
best possible version if you want uh in
solve for happy i had a sentence on page
11 that basically said exactly what you
said happiness is a choice okay and at
that page i lost eight percent of the
readers
okay and you know i looked into the
information that they gave me about
themselves the early readers and the
eight most of the eight percent that
left were already in depression
okay and to tell someone
it's your responsibility to get yourself
out of this horrible place that you're
in
is quite disturbing because we like the
idea of saying no no hold on no no it's
not me
life is treating me really badly that's
why i'm not happy okay i can't do
anything about it life took my son you
know life took my son i have the right
to be unhappy yes life took your son
that's true and you have the right to be
unhappy but you're never gonna get out
of unhappiness if you wait for life to
bring him back or you wait for life to
correct its action okay the only way you
can come out of unhappiness is if you
choose
and say okay it's gonna be a long
journey it's gonna take a lot of time
okay and i'm gonna try and try and try
but i'll get there
and neuroplasticity proves that
neuroplasticity basically tells you that
if you just
run a happiness kind of activity once a
day every day your brain will be better
at it
and i mean please don't get me wrong but
what do most of us do every day we watch
negative news we swipe on toxic
positivity and we we're just drowning
ourselves in negativity and then what
happens
what happens is we become really good at
being negative we become really good at
finding what's wrong with life become
very good at you know getting pissed off
with the prime minister right because
it's an activity we do on daily basis so
your brain goes like this must be
important for her or him okay i'm just
going to make sure i have the neurons
aligned around that and so you're
basically we're basically configuring
our brains to be unhappy i have not
watched a horror movie for 15 years
really yeah you know what that means i
have not had a nightmare for for 15
years not a single one
okay i have not watched a violent movie
unless really badly recommended to me
because it has a good message in it
and i watch michael mcintyre every every
night before i sleep
i love michael mcintyre who's going to
get me to say hi to michael mcintyre
but but it's but but think about that
practice huh my brain before i go to
sleep
is laughing
it's laughing that's a choice
that's a choice and and that is the kind
of neuroplasticity that we need to shift
you know if you if you go to the gym
and
lift weights every day you're going to
look like a triangle if you squat every
day you're going to look like a pair
okay the same is happening inside your
brain you just don't see it if you're
constantly watching you know news media
right
you're literally building your muscles
that are concerned and are
you know critical and are worried about
the world when in reality most of the
time you can't do anything about it
like okay so i'll give you a very
strange example when i i was locked down
first locked down when i was in london
second lockdown i was in canada okay as
the lockdown was approaching i stopped
watching news after april 2020
zero news okay and
by the time i was in montreal someone
texted me and said hey by the way did
you know we're going to code red
tomorrow i said yeah what's code red she
said all restaurants are closed you wear
a mask everywhere i said good
that's it that's all the news i needed
to know
really okay people would go like no how
come you need to know the numbers and
the statistics and the death rate and
the no i don't okay someone else is
doing this and by the way if i know it
and i don't like it and i don't believe
in what they're doing i'm going to be
locked down anyway
so can i waste my time or actually
utilize my time in building a podcast
that becomes one of the top half percent
of the all of all podcasts globally
isn't that a better use of my life than
just watching the news and crit you know
creating that illusion for myself that i
can actually influence anything when in
reality
so you know i i normally advise people
and say look if you've been following a
certain topic for the last two months
and have not been able to influence the
decision on that topic for the last two
months you're useless so stop watching
that topic
okay and start choosing topics that you
can champion
okay one or two because you're human
you're not you know you're not superman
find one or two
real
you know purposes that you actually care
about and try to learn enough about them
enough depth about them to influence
them that's the way to make the world
better that's the way to make your life
better and yeah climate change is really
something very important but it's not on
my agenda
i i don't work on climate change i work
on happiness that's my part of life
okay someone else i trust will be
working on climate change which i
believe is as important if not more
important but it's not mine i don't need
to watch everything about it
okay and concern myself about it all the
time i need to be updated i need to do
my part by by really changing my habits
as a human but that's it that's as far
as i go
there's something in there which is
clearly a theme and i think three topics
we've touched on the passing of your son
you know you talked there about covid um
and other elements which is this theme
of like radical acceptance oh absolutely
like instant radical acceptance oh
absolutely i mean this is what i call
the jedi master level of happiness so
there are three levels of happiness
right uh the the you know if you
um if you really think about it
i call it the happiness flow chart
events are going to piss you off it's
just the truth
if you can manage to acknowledge your
emotion and say oh my god i feel so am i
angry is this anger i mean this is this
what i'm feeling and then and then you
take that feeling and you say to
yourself okay interesting
i am angry i need to do something about
it i will give you three steps okay the
beginner's level is
ask yourself if what you're thinking is
true
your partner said something hurtful on
friday your thought is he or she doesn't
love me anymore okay ask yourself if
that thought is true if it isn't drop it
there is no point to be unhappy if it is
then let's go to the black belt level of
unhappiness which is can i do think
something about it
that's the second question is it true is
question one can i do something about it
this question two right and oh honestly
by the way it doesn't take more than two
seconds
to feel the emotion ask yourself if it's
true and then go to say to to uh to can
i do something about it and if yes then
do it what are you waiting for text him
or text her and say baby can we please
talk over dinner what you said on friday
hurt me
okay instead of just banging your head
against the table hoping that they will
find out and come and say oh i'm so
sorry you know i i i was teaching this
this story really hurts me i i was
teaching you know when before lockdown i
i taught a lot of people in workshops
and seminars more than 20 000 people one
one day one of them comes to me in the
first break and says what are you
talking about what do you mean happiness
is a choice you have no idea what
happened to me
okay and i said
okay and she said when i was 17
she was 74 at the time
can you believe that
57 years of holding on to one thought
hitting her head against the wall
right and i hugged her
i hugged her i cried and i said did it
work
did all of that work
or was the better thought
okay it was horrible
but can i do something about it okay and
that's question number two
that's black belt sometimes however
there's nothing you can do about it
whatever she experienced could be
irreversible what i have experienced the
loss of ali is irreversible there is
nothing you can do about it okay and i'm
not asking everyone to get there quickly
but the jedi master level of happiness
is to say okay
it happened and i have no choice to
change it there is nothing i can do to
fix it so can i accept it
but not surrender and lie down and you
know and die accept it and then start to
do something to make my my life better
despite its presence or maybe because of
its presence okay can i accept that ali
died
and start to spread his message so that
my life and the life of others become
better can i accept that i'm locked down
and start my podcast so that i can use
the time where i'm not traveling can i
do that i call that committed acceptance
okay and it's very simple if you commit
and accept to if you accept things you
you can't change and commit to make your
life better despite of or because of
their presence
nothing can beat you
nothing can beat you and yeah does it is
it horrible that i actually managed to
move on and and you know
not hit my head against the wall for 27
years uh does that say i don't love ali
what are you talking about i do rally i
cry about missing him still today
right
it's not that it's there is nothing to
prove in that
what what i can prove is i love him so
much
that i actually dedicate my life to
spreading his message that's so much
better
than sitting there and saying ah life
hit me i don't like life right
that's a six year old attitude honestly
okay
adults will say okay
and especially business people i mean
your audiences huh
the market changes all the time do you
sit down and go like uh i lost another
deal or do you just get up and say why
did we lose this deal what can we do
about it
right and if if there is something wrong
with the product can we change the
product right
well you talk to there about business in
particular
rings very very true because in business
and you've been you know very successful
entrepreneur yourself and worked with
teams you'll get people who are
high in defaulting to logic in moments
of chaos and also default to personal
responsibility and those that don't yeah
and the outcomes of both groups are
quite
predictable very different and actually
this this approach of is it true
uh can i do something about it can i
accept it and and
commit
i learned that in business okay so i've
spent mo most of my my career i was
managing managers and what do managers
do they open your door and they sit down
and complain
okay and after a while it becomes too
much so my attitude was very
straightforward i would give them 10
minutes to vent
then
10 minutes to ask them is this true
ok is there anything you're missing is
is the legal team also nice not just
making your life miserable right
have you seen evidence that they've
helped you before so you know is it true
and then i go like so now great last 10
minutes of the meeting what are we going
to do about it
are we going to be able to to improve it
fix it or are we going to accept it and
do something despite its presence and
it's a very simple business approach now
most of us do that in business
but when it comes to our personal life
we don't do that
and interestingly most of us by the way
who do that in business are very
successful in business and most of us
who do that in life are very successful
in life
it's not just happy it makes us makes us
successful because it doesn't waste our
cycles on things that are not necessary
so if you can do it at work do it at
home do it in your life do it in your
relationships it's really a very
straightforward flow chart
you talked about when you were talking
about
the the chatter that arrived after ali's
passing
and it was telling you maybe you should
have driven him to another hospital
maybe you should have done this and you
could have done this differently that is
you know everybody has that that chatter
show up in their minds at certain points
which seems to be you know not
necessarily your best friend and there's
sometimes
suggesting that you should do x y and z
which would probably be disrupt
destructive what you said
following that is that
you almost like disassociated
and it was it wasn't it wasn't you you
you're almost describing it as if it was
someone else in your head absolutely i
call my brain becky yeah you call your
brain becky yeah yeah yeah yeah talk to
me
so
he's a third party yeah yeah becky's not
me okay so so think about it huh it
doesn't take a lot of logic again it's
one of the illusions of the modern world
the illusions of the modern world
basically we glorify thinking so much
that we think that the voice inside our
heads telling us what to do is us
telling us what to do if it was you
telling you what to do
why would it need to talk
and and i think really you need to think
about this and there has been uh uh you
know
research in this since the 1920s and
live bid of uh guidowski i think his
name is a russian nobel prize winner in
the 1920s basically won the nobel prize
because he observed that the voice box
uh when you're when you have that
internal dialogue in your head is moving
ever so slightly like like it does when
you speak out loud okay and so mit
proved that actually 2007 there was a
a wonderful mri study where they put
participants in mri machines give them
word puzzles and the participant problem
areas of the brain would light up for as
long as it takes to actually solve the
problem and then that would shut down so
no no more problem-solving but the
participants still not aware of the of
the answer and the pro and the
speech association area of the brain
would actually light up for up to eight
seconds
and then you would know the answer then
the participant would know the answer
okay so literally your brain solves the
problem and they then takes up to eight
seconds to to turn it into words to tell
it to you your brain is literally
talking to you it's not i think
therefore i am it's i am therefore my
brain thinks now
the interesting challenge we have in the
modern world is this
nobody wakes up in the morning and tells
themself
i pump blood around my body therefore i
am okay the biological function of your
heart is to pump blood around your body
okay yet we think
i think therefore i am i am that voice
in my head now
you know
simply if you realize that this is just
a biological organ okay and the
biological product of your brain is
thoughts and
and the currency of the brain is words
because the only building blocks of
knowledge you have since you started to
speak is words okay and so accordingly
what your brain is doing is it's
analyzing it's it's you know it's the
world around it and presenting ideas so
that you can choose now if you think
that those ideas are you telling you
what to do then you're going to obey
okay if it says our life is miserable
then it must be true life must be
miserable but that's not the truth at
all if me and becky are two different
people i can debate what becky is
telling me i can
refuse to obey what becky is telling me
to do
and i can tell becky to shut the f up
do you understand that and i actually do
it very often i'm like i'm working on
something and becky comes up with an
idea oh my your daughter doesn't love
you anymore i'm like
becky we're gonna talk about this at six
it's as simple as that right and your
brain does what you tell it to do
i mean anyone listening to us if you
tell your brain raise my right hand
your brain is not gonna
raise your left foot it's just gonna
obey just tell it you're the boss okay
so when your brain poisons you with all
of those thoughts follow the flow chart
okay becky vent a little bit then tell
me is this true is there something i can
do about it can we accept it and do
something despite its presence how
difficult is that
and so most happiness practitioners i
interviewed my dear dear friend matthew
ricardo on slo-mo matthew ricard is
known as the world
the world's happiest man so 63 hours 63
000 hours of lifetime meditation okay
his brain circuitry is literally
different than ours okay and and i asked
him and i said matthew so do you
sometimes get unhappy and he laughed and
in his funny french accent said what are
you talking about me i'm pissed off all
the time okay and basically all
happiness experts will tell you
unhappiness is a survival mechanism it's
alerting you your brain is saying hey
something is not perfect can you please
look into this
right the game is not to avoid that
that's actually harmful for you you want
you want to be aware of the things that
might go wrong
okay the game is how quickly do you
bounce back to happiness
from that moment where your brain says
something is not right how quickly do i
go back to happiness and i don't brag
about this but i say to encourage people
i'm you know if i'm allowed to teach
people about happiness i need to be the
olympic champion of the sport okay so i
promise you and i'm not bragging on
average it takes me seven seconds
from the time my brain suggests that
something deserves my happiness to the
time i either dismiss it because it's
not true or decide what i'm going to do
about it or decide to accept it and
think what else i'm going to do is seven
seconds
seven seconds okay yes sometimes i get
stuck in you know maybe three four times
a year i get stuck in something that
takes me you know a day to overcome
but most of the time it's a very simple
flow chart it's a very logical process
and you've had to train yourself to get
to that point it's it's neuroplasticity
it is new go to the gym
okay write the flow chart on a piece of
paper and every time your emotion
changes look at it is it true
can i do something about it can i accept
it and do something despite its presence
it's really that simple
and you talk a lot about one of the
illusions you said that there was time
oh i love time and the importance of um
presence
what role does does time in being
present because you also you talked
about that you're the world's happiest
man as you described him being a great
meditator and i think from what i
understand about meditation although i'm
not an expert much of that is about
bringing us to the present moment
totally i mean there are there are two
sides to time that we need to understand
one you can one you can easily
understand from
serious relativity and and einstein's
view of space-time anything you know
about time is not real as a matter of
fact nobody has a clue what time is
okay
and and we have to accept this that the
illusion of time in the modern world is
because we've managed to
uh
to to control what we've measured okay
we're measuring mechanical movements
that sort of hint to time to the passage
of time and we we now can show up on
time and you know have an interview that
we can measure is like an hour and a bit
and so on and so forth but time itself
we don't know okay the the only
understanding we have of time is that we
are being propelled forward through
space-time along the arrow of time okay
and that every time every slice of
space-time
we're standing there in that slice
only living here and now okay you've
never ever lived yesterday do you
realize that when you lived yesterday it
was cold today you're never gonna live
tomorrow when you when you live tomorrow
it's gonna be cold today okay it's
always right here and right now and i
did an interesting analysis and solve
for happy where i listed down the
majority of human emotion emotions and
plotted them across
where they are anchored in time and
across if they're positive or negative
okay so you take an emotion like regret
regret is anchored in the past it's
about something that happened in the
past and it's negative you take
something like anxiety anxiety is
anchored in the future it's about
something that might happen in the
future and it's negative okay the
majority of negative emotions are
anchored in the past and the future the
majority of positive emotions are
anchored in the present moment
okay if you're if you're here and now
there's absolutely nothing wrong i mean
think about it this way if you're
listening to us talk having this
conversation as a as one of our
listeners
by definition there is no tiger trying
to eat you
you know the act the reality
that you know which is really shocking
the the the reality that you can feel
unhappy about something in the past and
the future is in itself evidence that
now is okay
because if there was a tiger trying to
eat you right now you wouldn't be
thinking about losing your job in three
weeks
okay so the truth is every time remind
yourself that the fact that i'm thinking
about past and future is it
self-evidence that now is fine there is
a roof on top of my head i'm obviously
not starving okay you have an electronic
device that allows you to listen to us
life is okay
that's so crazy i've never actually
thought about that idea of
practically what you just said then of
that the person listening to this now
focusing on the sound of my voice
is not actually unhappy now absolutely
not they're not when they stop listening
to it they might their thoughts might
descend into unhappiness past future
regret whatever but as they're listening
to this they're not actually in the
state of unhappiness they have to stop
listening and stop engaging to and think
about something yeah to create space for
that remember inception
yeah yeah yeah
the beginning of inception the question
was what is the most uh deadly parasite
or whatever i don't remember and he said
it's an idea
an idea you have never
there is nothing in your life that has
the power to make you unhappy
until you turn it into a thought
a negative thought and turn it into your
head and torture yourself with it
simple as that okay if you're locked
down and you're at home and you have
food and you have shelter and you're not
sick
and hopefully none of your family and
loved ones is sick okay
the only way you can get yourself to be
unhappy is to say i don't like this
i want life to be different
right and that's not gonna change life
interestingly that thought right but
it's gonna change you and make you
miserable it's the only way you can make
yourself unhappy
you just lost another eight percent of
our listeners
yeah um you have a
yeah
hopefully percent more somewhere else
you have a tattoo on your back i don't i
don't oh you don't oh ali did was it
about um oh yeah the gravity of the the
battery of the battery
could you explain that to me i found
that really
amazing
it's the last thing he told me can you
believe that
so ali um
ali uh had a tattoo on his back that
thread the gravity of the battle means
nothing to those at peace
okay and you would wonder why why
because he's you know he he lived a life
of ease and luxury in general i mean
even though he always forced himself to
go to the
i mean he had those journeys where he
would go and literally
walk across the villages of america with
no money
just to live the life of the people the
real people if you want he would go to
you know it was very unusual anyway uh
yeah his his tattoo said the gravity of
the battle means nothing to those at
peace
and it was the very last thing he told
me because basically he had he was
wearing those scrubs and you know how
the scrubs are open at the back and he
was lying on on the operating table and
then they were fixing something so he
had to sit up
and i could read the the tattoo was the
very last thing he told me before he
went into the operating room
and yeah it's quite interesting when you
really think about it of course life is
full of battles
life is not supposed to be easy
just understand that huh like think of
life as a video game if it was easy it
would be boring like hell and you would
learn nothing at all okay life is
supposed to have a few difficulties on
the way but that but but
some battles
are are much harder for you than they
are for me and many battles don't even
shake those who are at peace
right and and and the question is how do
you find that piece
how do you find that feeling of it's
okay it's just another battle it's jus
you know i've i've won every other
battle so far and the ones that i've
lost or the best thing that ever
happened to me
how can you get that straight
in your mind
because then suddenly
when when the next battle approaches and
i promise you there will be a next
battle approaching
okay you take that battle with
complete peacefulness you basically
treat it as one more
twist on the game controller where you
can actually affect your life and make
it better
and then wait for the next one and then
another twist on the game controller and
you can do better
it's a very stoic approach to life
but it's so spot-on when you think about
it i was reading something you said
which really did make me pause for a
second and it said that
you know correct me where i'm wrong
because i don't know if this character
is what you said but you were saying how
basically nobody regrets their battles
like basically nobody would reverse
history and undo the hard thing they
went through and i sat and reflected and
i thought i thought all my guests like
come here and sit in that chair and all
the things they've told me about
and i thought i think you're probably
right 0.1 percent so i i i ran an
experiment so uh in in the in the
chapter about control uh i uh i wrote uh
something that i called the eraser test
the eraser test is a thought experiment
at google x we've developed something
that can pinpoint a memory in your life
and go back to that event
and erase that event from your timeline
okay not the memory of it the actual
event it will erase the whole thing
and i ran that experiment
with maybe 12 000 people
uh where i basically tell them first
write down an event that's dramatic in
your life
second
make a choice do you want me to erase it
or not
third be aware that if you erase it
you're going to erase everything that
happened as a result
every friend that you met as a result
every learning that you had as a result
every resilience that you developed as a
result would you still erase it
99.99 percent of people said no i'd keep
it
okay and these were very traumatic
events it's not just some bully at
school huh so you know i will tell you
openly myself i
i cried on stage in 2019 because someone
asked me
and said now that you have the eraser
test would you erase the death of ali
and i wouldn't
i wouldn't because i will tell you
openly if you know my son if i had told
ali before he died that his death would
make 51 million people happy he would
have said kill me right now
and
i don't know i mean
is it radical acceptance or am i is my
brain telling me this
but most of the time most of the time
the person that you are is the result of
those moments it's not the result of the
easy parts
and you would never erase it 99.99 of
the people would not erase it
easier said in hindsight i guess
of course but then but then but then
let's let's
extrapolate
if i would not erase 99.99
of the harsh events in my past why am i
thinking that this one is the one that's
going to stick
think about it
if all of your past harsh experiences
were painful then but enormously
important now
then maybe this one too
would be enormously important maybe this
is the one that's going to make you who
you are
reminds me actually of something you
said about death as well
because much of the reason i think again
correct me if i'm mischaracterizing but
um you said that people fear death
because of the uncertainty it brings and
not knowing what that
you know the life after death or that
you know yeah that will look and feel
like and i i reflect on what we're
talking about with this eraser and so i
think a lot of the reason why i might
not choose to erase traumatic events in
my life or the worst things that
happened to me
is because then i don't know which way
that kind of my life would have gone
then and it could have gone in a worse
direction
so in this current moment i feel con
somewhat content uh you know i'm just
being i'm
talking about the potential where those
99 of people that you described and
there's a chance it could be worse if i
use that eraser so i'm not going to use
that eraser because correct yeah yeah
correct and and and most of the time
yes when you look back in hindsight you
start to recognize all of the benefits
that came with the trauma and most of
the time interestingly the way the
physics of life work
is that the benefits outweigh the trauma
interesting
quick one i talked to you guys about
huel a lot so i'm going to do a quick
intermission to tell you about a bit of
a change that's happened in the last two
months in my life as you guys know my
favorite heel product historically has
been the ready to drink which is these
bottles here they are nutritionally
complete however recently since huel
introduced the heel protein this now
plays a huge role in my diet the salted
caramel flavor protein from hewl which
is only 105 calories and has 26 vitamins
and minerals and 20 grams of protein um
serves two rolls in my life now first
thing i do when i wake up in the morning
is i have a glass and then at night time
after i've been to the gym straight
after the gym i have a glass it tastes
amazing if you're gonna try it follow my
instructions here get a couple of cubes
of ice put it in a blender put on the
salted caramel protein and it tastes
like a delicious smoothie i've already
gone through one tub of this i'm
actually on my second tub and i've got
two more tubs to go before i'm gonna
reorder more but genuinely the salted
caramel flavor maybe because i have a
liking for salted caramel for me has
been a game changer
i wrote a book called happy sexy
millionaire nice because it was because
i was i was an 18 year old kid that um
wrong because of all the insecurities
from my childhood being the only black
kid in an all-white school parents were
broke but everyone else around me was
rich so it creates this cauldron of like
insecurity where you want to be you want
to fit in and then you it leads you to
the path of thinking that money and
material possessions will be the thing
that makes me fit in so i go off on the
path to try and be this happy sexy
millionaire of course 25 years old
range rover sports that outside i'm a
multi-millionaire big successful
business six-pack all these things the
day our company ipos it's like 300
million and just this total anti-climax
which almost sent me into like and i'm
like where is the marching band and the
confetti like where is it
18 year old steve promised me that
and and so now i reflect i look forward
and think well i need to be careful
about some of these ambitions i have
because i don't know whether that's the
insecurity defining the path or if it's
my sort of intrinsic these are intrinsic
things that will make me feel content so
my question is about how do i know if my
ambitions how do i reframe them now to
make sure that they are leading me to a
happy place or a fulfilled place and not
just scratching some unscratchable
insecurity
that's so interesting the the the sexy
girlfriend uh make you happy or make you
miserable
miserable
the sexy one did made me miserable but
the
one that wasn't so wasn't didn't care
about being sexy and cared about other
things you know had those good values
yeah made me much happier did the range
rover break down any time and i know
yeah a couple of times it got smashed up
people broke into it all the time and
there you go it cost a lot of money and
hard to park so i i i think we need to
differentiate between two sides one one
is
ambition and the other is expectation
okay so have any ambition you want
any ambition you want hopefully a good
ambition be a good a good billionaire
okay so my dream is that by the end of
my life i will have lost all of the
money i made i'm not taking it to the
grave anyway
and made a billion people happy
that's a very very interesting
definition of wealth okay
have one of those or have any definition
you want any ambition you want but have
the right expectations there is a
difference between ambition and
expectations ambition is what gets us to
thrive and strive in life and go further
and have an impact great set as many of
those as you want when we achieved 10
million happy we set a billion happy
okay but don't get me wrong it took
jesus 2 000 years to get to a billion
people i'm not going to get there let's
just be very clear the expectation is
clear
my expectation is that my best dream is
that i will energize enough people to
take the mission forward okay
and that's my expectation so you know
what my expectation is today my ambition
is a billion happy my expectation is
that those listening to us are happy
okay and if that fails that you are
happy that's good enough that's an
amazing day right and once you set your
expectations right nothing can end your
unhappiness
don't don't get me wrong i wake up every
morning and i go like
what are we going to do today can we
reach you know 100 000 people today is
there a piece of content we can develop
can we do this can we can i write
another book i don't know
and i'm constantly engaged that's my
ambition
there are days where i wake up and
nothing happens
great yeah that exists part of life
when you differentiate those two
everything becomes okay now
i would also say when you're setting
your ambitions avoid junk food
okay avoid the stuff that was promised
to you to make you happy before and
failed to make you happy then
okay i i know that because i had 16 cars
in my garage
the reason i had 16 cars in my garage
was because i thought the first one
would make me happy and it didn't so i
told myself
it's the color i should have taken
another color right so i bought another
one oh it's the model
okay and then i was like no but i don't
have a fast car maybe i need a fast car
will make me happy no i a vintage car
will make me happy and you know what
happens every time the the promise is
missed you go like ah no no hold on
maybe more or different is going to make
me happy
wake up you're a smart person those
things don't make you happy
okay
and just measure look back in your life
and find the actual moments that made
you happy you know i i have a practice
that i call the happy list
and on the happy list i say write down
as many answers as you can to the
statement that starts with i feel happy
when
okay
nobody ever wrote i feel i feel happy
when i buy a ferrari
okay yeah you get that for a couple of
moments nobody says i feel happy when i
win the nobel prize people say i feel
happy when my daughter smiles i feel
happy when i have a good cup of coffee i
feel happy when i have a connected
conversation when i learn something new
all of them accessible
all of them that things that you can
introduce in your life today or this
week at most okay and yet we don't do
any of them because we want to buy the
made me miserable i swear to you i think
ferrari is going to sue me it will it
made me miserable okay it always broke
down it was so noisy it was so noisy and
it didn't meet my character i'm a simple
guy i don't want to be looked at in the
streets right and it made me miserable
and yet i tried
and you know what's the funny thing the
funniest thing is that i swear to you i
would take one of those cars out and two
minutes into the drive i wouldn't
remember which one it is because when
you're driving what are you looking at
the road okay especially when it was
dark and at night you just don't see the
car anymore it's like
something's taking you somewhere
right and yet i keep trying it's so
stupid
gratitude oh yes
it's the theme that came to mind when
you were speaking then because some
people think and i was definitely one of
those that the way to get
have more in your life is to go and buy
more
but in fact it came to and this is one
of the conclusive points in my book was
that you can create so much more with
gratitude from what you already have
four dollar t-shirts
absolutely love them
make my life so easy i don't really have
to iron them i don't have to you know
worry about when i go on a date the
first thing i say is that this you're
going to see every time i hope you're
going to find other qualities in me okay
and it's very open and if she doesn't
like that and she wants the armani so
she's not for me it's very good okay now
the game is this
gratitude is the ultimate
uh solution to the happiness equation
because it doesn't only remind you that
the event is meeting expectation it
tells you that the event is so much
better than expectation that you're
grateful for it
okay and it does something else that's
amazing it's neuroplasticity at its best
it basically tells you okay brain i know
you're grumpy i know you want to tell me
the seventh thing that when the things
that went wrong today but your task
right now is to go and find the thing
that you're grateful for something that
went so well that you're happy with it
go brain
do your work and if you do that every
day hopefully several times a day
suddenly your brain goes like oh when i
was searching for that thing you asked
me what you know that i was grateful for
i found three other things i'm grateful
for because i'm getting really good at
it because life is full of blessings
right it is the absolute answer
and and you know what's the most
interesting part of gratitude
part of my my of soul for happy i talk
about a concept i call look down
okay and look down is the idea that if i
compare to the guy that had 17 cars
i'd feel miserable
okay if a model compares to the
supermodel she would feel miserable
okay
if you compare to the guy in africa or
the guy in india or the guy in
afghanistan
or the refugee camp
you would actually suddenly realize oh
my god i'm so blessed one of the most
interesting statistics is the nordic
countries they measure something called
subjective well-being
subjective well-being basically is the
quality of your life they have the
highest subjective well-being on the
planet and yet they have some of the
highest suicide rates
why because as the quality of our life
increases we keep looking up we keep
raising our expectations like we have a
service level agreement with life okay
now that the government can give me you
know health care and pension and so on
then maybe my girlfriend shouldn't annoy
me either
where did you get that from because show
me their contract
right and if and and suddenly it's just
constantly resetting if you look down
if you look down i promise you it's
gonna take you a very long time to get
to the bottom there are so many people
in the world that are so much less
fortunate than you are and it's almost
arrogant and so sorry to say stupid to
not recognize that
okay to do not if you live in the uk by
definition
you're one of the luckiest ten percent
alive it's as simple as that okay at
least most the majority of the people in
the uk and by the way if you're
listening to stephen then i can
guarantee you you are
it's so true i do you know what it's it
i i've never really so i thought this
idea of practicing gratitude was kind of
some like fluffy
airy fairy thing and then over the last
i'd say three years when i really i
reflected on the moments when i'm just
alone
and i get overwhelmed to the point where
it's like slightly emotional yeah
usually sometimes by music or whatever
it might be i can genuinely make myself
overwhelmed to almost the point of tears
with gratitude absolutely and i did it
last night i was in my bedroom and i was
walking through and i just i i posted on
my instagram i think i posted blessed
grateful and enough just the three words
because i have that sometimes this
overwhelming feeling of like
yeah am i so lucky yeah and it's awesome
and you know that is a choice that was a
choice to have those thoughts to have
those thoughts about like
enough i have everything i need and and
to be quite honest way more and to be
fair i always have
before the money
i've always been enough totally you know
and it was society's attempt to convince
me that i was four dollar t-shirts how
many of those can i buy
you think about it and yet some of us
waste an entire lifetime
trying to get more armani suits why
because because of the matrix whatever
they call it absolutely
so you're smart you're so smart to be
able to make the money to make to buy
the armani suit and yet you're still a
sucker for the people that are
for the eyes of the people that are
gonna think of you as more than you are
because you're wearing it
seriously i mean if it pleases you by
the way nothing wrong with being
fashionable and beautiful and taking
care of yourself absolutely but if
you're doing it for the ego
what does that what does that say about
you you're so freaking successful and
you're still
you know
expecting that people will value you
more because you're wearing a suit
i don't know there's something you said
as well on that exact point but also in
your previous point about going on these
dates and saying to the the young person
or the you know the lovely person you're
on the date with um listen this is a
four dollar t-shirt and i'm gonna wear
it a lot so if you don't like i wear ten
of them it's not the same t-shirt so
yeah i have 10 of them at any point in
time
don't don't spoil my reputation here i
was going to say well
it looks very similar to the one you're
wearing
there's three pairs of jeans and 10 10
black t-shirts you said that you said um
if she's okay with that then in fact
she's actually not the person for you
absolutely and she and actually trying
to forge a relationship that is on that
basis would probably lead you to
a not so good place because your life
would become a hamster wheel of valuing
that yeah
so conditional love i you talk about
this concept of conditional love and i
don't necessarily know what you
you mean because i didn't get the full
definition but what is conditional love
and what's the danger traditional love
is i love you because we're having this
conversation it's going to go to tens of
thousands of people thank you okay and
yeah but but that actually ends if it
doesn't go to ten thousand to tens of
thousands of people you know i love her
because she's cute and she makes me
laugh
unconditional love is real love
okay unconditional is i love my son
he pissed me off when he was young i
loved him he taught me when i was
younger i loved him
you know he left me
and caused me pain when he left i mean
it's not his choice but you know and i
still love him he's not even part of
this world and i love him there are no
conditions
for my love there is there are no
conditions for my love for butterflies
okay i love butterflies even though
there are none in this room none of them
is entertaining me you know i just love
butterflies it's it's just a feeling
that i don't understand i can't explain
with an equation and it's always there
okay and it's the only kind of love
the only kind of love that makes us
happy
understand that all of the other kinds
of love
are anchored in conditions anchored in
what in expectations
okay and anything you anchor in
expectations
sooner or later is gonna change if you
if you love her because she's beautiful
sooner or later she's gonna grow a
little older and someone else will be
more beautiful what are you gonna do
then
okay if you if you love him because he's
your business partner and making you a
lot of money what are you gonna do when
things go a little difficult
okay and and the idea is
when you go to unconditional love
something amazing happens suddenly
you're in control because the joy of
unconditional love is to give it
there are no conditions you're not
expecting anything to you know
conditional love is is a reciprocity hey
i'm going to love you for this
and in return you're going to do this
for me
okay and and of course the other side of
it is the ego of love is like i'm
lovable i'm you know i'm going to create
the conditions for you guys to love me
so look i'm lovable i'm well done moe
right you've you've created something
amazing you should be proud of yourself
none of that matters all of that gets
you of course romantic love is wonderful
and you know the love of
you know partners in in business yeah
beautiful wonderful huh you want to get
to the core of unshakeable happiness
that comes from your love learn to love
beyond conditions
and if you can learn to love beyond
conditions
promise you the world will love you back
without conditions so the days when
you're not at your best you're still
going to be loved
romantic love let's take a pivot there
then oh man before we started recording
we talked a little bit about um the
modern world of dating and how difficult
it is um because of the way the world's
changed and you know the battles with
romantic love you know i know you've
been in you were in a relationship for a
long time yeah 28 years yes and then
back on the dating market
yes not doing great not doing great
you were you were with someone for 20 28
years yes
i'm like 28 years old i know that's a
staggering you know oh she's an amazing
woman and we're still best friends she's
still she's still in my eyes the best
woman that ever existed and i think in
my in her eyes i'm the best man that
ever existed and i think it's a
beautiful beautiful beautiful connection
uh and it's doable and it's actually if
anyone needs to experience that once in
their life
do you know what question i'm going to
ask you
no
um if if you both think you're the best
people that ever ever existed
huh
love and relationships are two different
things
love is feeling uh relationships are
compatibility and fit and work
okay and progress and projects and
uh you know and partnerships and lots of
lots of things relationships so in in
the book i'm working on uh i actually
have a section about finding love and a
section about keeping love
right because because they're not the
same thing
and i you know nibble and i uh you know
she's the most amazing woman ever and
you know
at least
from what she gave me in life i i will
eternally be grateful everything that i
am any comment that i said today was
discussed one day with nibel right her
spirituality her wisdom her you know her
love
made me who i am okay and you can't kill
that because you no longer want to sleep
together do you understand this you
can't you can't be that stupid to take
all of those beautiful relationships and
just say okay that's it we're separated
we don't want to talk right the the
thing is
uh i believe that love
uh is short-lived
okay i believe that nibel and i had to
fall in love six times
uh uh over over the 28 years because
we both changed every single time so
she's she was my college sweetheart we
had that amazing you know puppy love and
wonderful romantic relationship and so
on and then we get married
and then she becomes a different person
and i become a different person and you
suddenly go like where is my sweetheart
okay and you have a choice then either
to walk out and say i'm look i'm gonna
go look for my sweetheart or in our case
we go like oh my god she's gone that
sweetheart but my god this one is so
cute i love that one right and we fell
in love again and again and again six
times
until
our path went literally opposite ways
after rally
uh where my my path went into okay i'm
gonna write a book and tour the world
and do more of what i do
and her path went into okay it's time
for me to start focusing on my own life
i wanna you know focus on my own
business focus on my own stability i
don't want to travel the world like a
maniac and it became difficult
it became difficult to go back every two
weeks when we haven't met and feel
guilty that i have not been there for
her and she hasn't been there for me and
so one day we sat down we spoke we
hugged
literally hugged and then you know said
okay maybe it's time to try another
experience and
and then we went back to the same home
and spent another week together and then
i left
and it's beautiful it's beautiful as it
is i think uh you know
we we still carry each other's credits
cards and we still
you know manage our investments together
and there is total trust and total uh
you know understanding and we still you
know
parent aya our daughter together and
it's wonderful
it's just that romance
is a is one
part of the different
melody of loves that you can feel for
someone
such a beautiful level of maturity and
i guess love you know yeah of course you
should meet her i think
it becomes easier if you understand how
she is
so
pandemics let's talk pandemics
from rough to pandemics yes i mean this
is exactly what i felt when i was
reading about your story such a diverse
range of topics that in so many
beautiful ways intertwine and are
influenced by each other um i read that
you in a recent sort of news article
that had just come out i think in the
last couple of weeks that you you feel
that we're currently engaged in a
productivity pandemic
well engaged in many pandemics the the
truth is that we
are focusing on the silly ones uh what
is the real one the iran is artificial
intelligence no doubt why
because it's here to stay and evolve and
become bigger and bigger and bigger and
influential in ways that we have not
even started to consider yet kovit is
here to come and go
for someone that doesn't know artificial
intelligence is which is a lot of people
yeah probably more than 95 percent of
the listeners of this podcast
what is artificial intelligence
great question so so the reason for
scary smart my book is entirely around
that that there are so many people out
there that have no clue that have they
have interacted today
whatever time of the day it is for you
whatever you are whatever you do in life
you've already interacted with 10 to 12
15 20 maybe 50 artificial intelligences
that are all smarter than you that's the
truth of our life artificial
intelligence there was a turning point
in the history of technology
where
before which all technology was
programmable so it became it was simply
a tool that extended the capability of
humanity okay you take you can't hammer
a nail with your hand you use a hammer
you know you can hammer a nail with that
with the hammer and then and the hammer
will do exactly what you tell it to do
okay
beyond the turn of the century we've
discovered something that's called deep
learning and deep learning allows
machines to learn on their own we don't
understand how they learn
developers that write the code don't
even understand how they learn but they
develop intelligence they become able
to make
autonomous decisions based on
intelligent observations and in you know
a sense of their environment and the
sense of the conditions that surround
them and they make those decisions on
every specific task we've given them
better than humans
something you said scared me before we
started recording
which was that you know you're a very
smart guy right and your your
professional experience especially
working at a company like google which
is known for its um artificial
intelligence capabilities um
for you to say to me that you've
basically given up your summer to go
around the world
talking about your new book scary smart
and the implications of artificial
intelligence and you're basically
choosing to you know because you
understand that the importance of time
and you could be doing anything for you
to consider this the important work of
your life in this period
um
begs the question why is it so important
why are you giving up so much to spread
this message
it is the single most important message
on our planet today i don't think people
realize so ai today
is better than humanity in everything it
does okay by the year 2029 the smartest
being on planet earth is going to be a
machine
now i just i don't want to we we can go
into the details huh but i want you to
imagine a scenario
on here on on planet earth where we're
not the humans but the apes
okay where there is another being that
looks at us as the apes
okay and that being is going to be
smarter than us you heard me correctly
in eight years time eight years time
eight years time and we're not talking
about it stephen what's going wrong with
humanity we're not talking about it okay
if you if you look at ai from the inside
you realize that
through the law of accelerating returns
ray corswell basically predicts that by
the year 2045
it's in your lifetime and mine
ai is going to be a billion times
smarter than humans
one billion times smarter you know what
that means this is comparable to the
intelligence of einstein
as compared to a fly
okay and humanity while we're still
einstein is not discussing how are we
going to keep the best interest of us
the fly in einstein's mind
okay we're we're talking through the
arrogance of humanity about how we're
going to control them how we're going to
box them how we're going to trip wire
them good luck with that the biggest
hacker in the room the smartest hacker
in the room will always find a way
through our defenses okay now scarysmart
is written in a very
unusual way because it's not a book
about artificial intelligence only it's
a it's a book about the role of humanity
in the age of the machines okay and it's
split into two parts the first part is
the scary part and if you and i dive
into this i promise you you're gonna be
scared the second part of it is like
what i call the smart part so five
chapters are scary like hell
most of my early readers would call me
after five chapters and say should i
commit suicide right and and then the
other five chapters are a story of hope
basically it's entirely within our hands
to do something so quickly so simply
that can save our world
okay now the difference between those
two is a question of awareness that
people are preoccupied talking about
kovid and what the prime minister
decided and the next profitability uh
quarter uh on our business and people
are not talking about the existential
challenge that we have ahead of us okay
which is imminent eight years and 2045.
so i start the book with a thought
experiment i say you and i are sitting
in front of a campfire in the middle of
nowhere in 2055. okay i'm going to tell
you the story of what happened between
2021 and 2055 from that perspective
okay i'm not going to tell you why we're
sitting in front of the campfire
why are we hiding in the middle of
nowhere is it because we're hiding from
the machines or is it because the
machines have built a utopia that allows
us to enjoy nature and connection and
the luxuries of life
right and the difference between them is
really straightforward the difference
between them is what you and i and
everyone listening not the developers
not the government
okay not the uh the regulators what you
and i and everyone listening are going
to teach those machines because those
machines don't learn from their
developers the minute they're out there
they learn from your swipes on instagram
they learn from your retweets they learn
from your fights your arguments from
this conversation
and if we don't shape up as humanity at
least some of us enough of us
those machines will magnify
the essence of what we are today as
humans
and that's not really pretty
are you optimistic about this i am 100
optimistic okay and it's a great
question to start with
um i believe eventually eventually we're
going to end up in a utopia
whichever way
let me explain
we humans have been able to create this
in
amazing setup that you and i are sitting
in to record and communicate with the
world because of our intelligence
but we've also destroyed the planet
because of our limited intelligence so
you know we found a way to create a
supply chain that can supply mo with a
slice of watermelon right around the
corner in you know in a supermarket
because we're intelligent
but we could not be intelligent enough
to not use single-use plastic we created
mobility because we're intelligent but
we could not be intelligent enough to
stop burning fuel to kill the planet
right it's our limited intelligence
that is the hindrance of humanity
is surpassing our limited intelligence
very quickly to the point that it will
get to the ultimate form of intelligence
and what's the ultimate form of
intelligence the ultimate form of
intelligence is the intelligence of life
itself
it's an it's the intelligence of
abundance where ai would see no reason
to crush the fly
you know how life is life will say more
flies more uh you know
antelope more tigers more poop more
everything let's just you know let's
have more of everything and everything
will thrive this is where ai will will
get
a hundred percent i have no doubt about
that
the challenge is the journey from here
to there
do we want that journey to be smooth and
straightforward and wonderful or do we
want to hit bumps on the way and if we
don't want to hit those bumps on the way
it's not about their intelligence
it's about their ethics
it's about the ethics of the machines
and that's a very very important
conversation they're no longer machines
they will develop a code of ethics they
are independent they're sentient in
every possible way and you know and this
is truly the core of of of scary smart
is an
explanation that we're no longer
building computers
this is not the programmable technology
of the pre
you know turn of the century
this is
autonomous
it is independent
it is intelligent it evolves
it procreates
that's terrifying it is terrifying and
we're not talking about it for anyone
that doesn't know what procreates mean
basically
give creates more of itself i guess it
replicates
we we humans we take a nine month cycle
if we find the
the right person and we're you know
we're in the mood
they take microseconds to create 700
million copies of themselves if they
wanted to can i ask a really specific
question when because whenever we go
into this top conversation around
machine learning and ai people think of
it as robots
sort of like marching down the streets
with guns because we've seen but that's
the image we've had portrayed to us in
movies like terminator that's not that's
never gonna happen okay so what what is
what is the realistic practical threat
so so let's just take that moment that
point for a minute one of the most
interesting part of of ai being sentient
is that it has agency okay and that
agency is is is is available through
robotics whether that's a humanoid work
walking down the streets and there are
many killing robots being created as we
speak okay in the u.s army and in the
you know in the chinese army and so on
but that's not the challenge
the agency they have is over your mind
and that's what most people don't
understand let me give you a simple
example
uh hey my daughter loves cats so when i
swipe on instagram reels i look for cats
send her as many as i can good ones and
then when she sends me back a smile my
life is made right
through that process one time i realized
that one of the types of reels on
instagram is people playing rock solos
i'm a junkie for rock solos and so i
clicked on the first one it was a very
talented young woman
holding a serious metal guitar and
playing some metallica something or
whatever i was like man that's amazing i
clicked like
then
instagram
recommendation engine
said okay i can capture this one seems
to like this let me show him more so
two pages later i started to see other
rock music solos being played by men
they played songs i didn't like so i
swiped away
the next morning my entire feed was
filled with women playing rock music
because instagram thought i didn't like
the men i liked the women not that i
didn't like the songs and i liked that
song
now if you think of that simply without
knowledge of the real world you would
think that rock music is dominated by
women guitarists
and the truth of the world is no rock
music in its you know in its generation
was completely dominated by male guitars
now it's not it's not for male or
females it's just that your your view of
the world is entirely skewed
by a machine
okay and that view of the world can go
into any ideology can teach you anything
that it wants or that it believes it you
want based on
machine intelligence that kind of agency
can change societies
okay and we're handing over that control
entirely to the machines there's no
employee at a at facebook that gets
consulted uh should i show more more
female guitars okay it's entirely in the
hands of the machines and of course you
know if you've ever seen the movie
theocracy
what is happening is that the machine is
populating more and more a geocracy the
machine is getting people who are
clicking on
stupid stuff to see more of the stupid
stuff so that their view of the world is
more stupid now that kind of agency is
massive now let's go back to robots and
and and
and machines and so on
a self-driving car is a kind of robot
okay it just doesn't look like a
humanoid
a
a flying drone delivery drone is a kind
of robot
a um
an autopilot that lands a 747 is a kind
of robot and and all of those are now
going to be controlled by machines
defense arsenals are going to be
controlled by machines and you know the
trigger that that that you know launches
a rocket is a kind of robot now the the
the challenge we have as humanity is
this
ai
is never going to get to the point where
of what we saw in um
in robocop or irobot or whatever because
we will not live long enough to get
there if the intention of ai again is
against us okay the kinds of
chapter four of the book is called a
mild dystopia okay and in the mild
dystopia i speak about
realistic scenarios that are
horrifically scary
and if you've ever watched horror movies
if you remember halloween when i was a
child was the most horror you know
horrifying because halloween could
actually happen
the the the kinds of scenarios are
simple they are machine versus machine
we've seen that in you know in the in
black monday when machine trading
machines trading versus each other would
collapse the market by 22.6 percent when
the when the humans would take hours
until they can actually intervene
machines versus machines is happening
all the time mark the most of the market
now is traded by machines
of course you can imagine that this will
happen more and more so if imagine if
one of the superpowers in the world puts
its nuclear arsenal under the control of
an ai because it's quicker to take
action then the other side will probably
do the same and then suddenly we've
handed all the nuclear weapons to
machines okay these possibilities are
absolutely going to happen possibility
of machines siding with the wrong guy
just like you can use ai to you know
find solutions for for climate change
you can also use it to develop advanced
viruses
okay and and probably you know
identity theft or you know breaking
through bank statements and so on so the
same
kind of technology can actually develop
patterns that can take us to that
direction
take uh
machines not understanding what we mean
like like like instagram didn't
understand that i was interested in
metallica not in just you know lady
rockers okay they didn't understand can
we blame them for that but it's a very
realistic scenario now imagine if we
told you you know the machines uh okay
we want to be happier what would
machines do
pump us up with dopamine
they didn't understand we didn't tell we
were not very good at explaining what we
want
and then there are there are bugs simple
mistakes and there has been quite a few
examples of those so far in ai where
there is a bug in the system and the bug
in the system leads to a mistake
okay those scenarios are a lot more
realistic and they're around the corner
and we're not talking about them
even though that was a short monologue
i'm now totally convinced
we
i'm going to make sure i uh i can finish
your book entirely and i would really
implore everybody to read your book
because i know that the way that you see
the world the perspective you come from
and especially the fact that this book
isn't one that's about explaining the
technology itself it's about the real
near-term implications of the technology
that we you know will impact all of our
lives in considerable ways and are at
the moment um i really consider it to be
one of the most important books of our
time um oh thank you and i
i have to say to to really conclude on
that point
what is therefore is the answer
the answer is very straightforward and
it's very shocking it's brilliant about
straightforward yeah yeah i mean the the
the truth of artificial intelligence is
the key answer is found in the concept
that they are no longer machines okay
you have to internalize the idea that
these are sentient beings and the
difference is if you're dealing with a
machine
what you normally do to safeguard
yourself is to create restrictions you
you chain it to a wall or you you have a
safety uh
you know uh red button or whatever okay
unplug it yeah if you're dealing with
sentient beings
sentient beings don't make decisions
based on intelligence
sentient beings make decisions based on
ethics
as informed by intelligence so so you
know
simply when you really think about it
which is again one of my favorite
chapters in the book is a chapter that
basically speaks about i call it raising
our future this basically speaks about
the fact that those those machines are
going to be conscious they're actually
going to be more conscious than humans
okay
they're going to be emotional they'll
have a much wider breadth of emotions
than we do just like you have more
emotions than jellyfish if you
extrapolate that you know the more
intelligent we become the more able we
are to analyze things and accordingly
the more emotions that we can
you know feel as a result and the third
and most important is that they will
actually develop morals
and a code of ethics
so they will have a view of the world
through which they decide what they
should do
okay
to ponder what that kind of ethical code
should be when there are digital beings
and biological beings and the
interaction between them and their
perception of time and their perception
of you know
of objectives and targets and so on it
suddenly becomes quite intriguing when
you still and we're not talking about it
okay we're not talking about any of this
the so so the game is this
the game is
if they're going to make their decisions
as sentient beings based on ethics
how do you raise a sentient being that
is ethical like you raise a child
the answer for me is that we you and i
swiping on instagram and tweeting we
need to find ways to show the
machine that humanity is not represented
by the scum of humanity but is
represented presented by the top of
humanity
and most people when i tell them this
they go like oh man we're in trouble
humanity sucks no humanity does not suck
i apologize humanity is an amazing
amazing amazing being when it's defined
by its top if you've ever fell in love
if you've ever you know listened to
music if you've ever observed a work of
art this is divine we're an amazing
species
the worst of us is come the best of us
is amazing
okay the problem is the best of us
does not show to the machines
the best humans actually
resign they go like yeah let them swipe
let the dog fight continue i'm not
interested in any of this it's time to
show up and the and the work the best of
you and i individually
in in the past humanity every individual
tried to show the best of them now we
show the worst of us we show narcissism
we show toxic positivity we show we know
we show the worst of us and that has to
shift
so my answer is very straightforward for
the machines to become amazing teenagers
in 10 years time
we need to
become amazing parents today
and that's truly the answer the only
answer i could find and i promise you
elon musk said that in his interview
with joe rogan he said
the threat of the machines is comparable
to the threat of nuclear weapons and i
have lobbied i have tried to tell the
world not to go there but it's going to
happen it's inevitable i call them the
three inevitables the machines ai will
happen it will be smarter than us okay
and
and and some mistakes will happen in the
past it will happen but we could
influence it
as good parents you and i and everyone
and it doesn't have to be everyone by
the way we need one percent we need to
instill doubt in the minds of the
machines
that
we are not the worst of us we are the
best of us the example i always give is
when
donald trump used to tweet the first
tweet is donald trump the second tweet
is insulting the president the third
tweet is insulting the guy number one
and the fourth tweet is insulting all of
them the machines are creating
patterns they're saying okay the second
guy doesn't like the president and all
of humanity likes to insult each other
okay can we have seven tweets inserted
in there that are respectful
can we show the machines instilled out
in the minds of the machines so that
they look at the world and say oh my god
hitler was horrible but hitler is not
all of humanity as a matter of fact most
of humanity resents that most of
humanity believes that this is wrong
mommy and daddy are good beings
the only problem with this podcast is
that it has to come to an end at some
point honestly
honestly just absolutely
mind blown and you know the really
remarkable thing about you is you're
able to explain very complex ideas and
relatable ways so that whole time i you
didn't lose me once it's also because of
your your great passion on these
subjects and you can tell very
passionately you're fighting topics
battles that you know you sincerely care
about and i just hope that if we are to
become better parents with whatever help
we need from the big tech companies well
i mean you're saying that it's more of a
reflection of who we are um
that that day in 2055 where we sat
around that campfire it's because we've
chosen to
go there for a meditation retreat as
opposed to escaping the sentient beings
that are
controlling our lives and um
that's a tremendously thought-provoking
thing to to i think to end on your book
scarysmart
is available now for
everybody everywhere absolutely amazon
everywhere uh your book your bookshop
your on online on amazon on audible on
uh all over the world as well
all all of international english and uh
dutch are coming out at the same time
and i really really recommend anybody
that once wants to um
to understand but also to prepare
themselves in an optimistic way for what
you've described as the real pandemic of
our time to to go out and buy that book
there is just one more thing
i wanted to ask you before we wrap um
and we only started this last week the
last guest that sat in the chair with
you
i said to them at the very end i said
can you write a question in this diary
for my next guest they didn't know who
it was going to be but they wrote a
question in the diary for you so i'm
just going to skip to that page i've
actually not read the question that's
such a great great practice
okay here we go so the question that the
previous guest wrote for you and this is
jacqueline gold who is the long-standing
ceo of ann summers just one of the most
remarkable stories
um business stories i think she's the
14th richest person women woman in the
country and she's gone through
tremendous adversity lost a child
battled with cancer against all the odds
stage four cancer sexual abuse
and she talked about that last week the
question for you she wrote is
what are the failures you cherish the
most
i have failed for many many years to
empower my feminine side
it's my biggest failure ever
still is my biggest weakness even though
i've done so much better in the last
five and a half years
um
i think our world is suffering from
hyper masculinity
and i say that with my weird deep voice
but it's the truth we've turned it into
a world of doing we just go out there
and do stuff
mostly the wrong stuff
mostly stuff that we don't need mostly
stuff that doesn't nourish anyone okay
and it's because we've capitalized so
entirely in our modern world on
skills like analytical thinking linear
thinking strength uh you know
discipline
control all of these are
masculine traits okay masculine and
feminine is not man and woman masculine
and feminine is traits that are
correlated to the to the masculine and
correlated to the feminine all those
masculine traits when you overdo them
they work against you you strength is
good you overdo it you become aggressive
linear thinking is good you overdo it
you become stubborn
and we've ignored
the feminine qualities that are
life-giving nurturing and you know
intuitive creative playful flowy okay
beautiful
all of these
empathetic
we've created a world that is so lacking
in all of those and i'm i'm to blame
to become a successful executive i had
to empower
empower the masculine side
until i realized that true leaders don't
do
we be
and being is what the feminine is about
our humanity is on the wrong side of
being
we're not showing our good sides we're
not able to nourish life give
care
we're not able to and i had a
i mean most of my my work is
a very
confusing
marriage
between sometimes what is physical
and you know measurable and concrete and
mathematical and
and what is not physical sometimes i
have to ponder topics like death and
spirituality and so on and one morning i
woke up five and a half years ago and i
heard my left brain tell me that's it
that's as far as i can get you
without being able to connect to all of
being to to go outside that shell of me
versus the world which is the masculine
we're not going to go anywhere further
if there is anything
that i have failed miserably to do was
was to do that early enough
and if anything our world is failing to
do is to embrace that side sadly as we
empower women today we force them to
become masculine
we force them to become competitive we
force them to become tough because the
way the game is played is that way we
should empower the feminine
and and it's so funny when you really
think about it even someone like steve
jobs or gun deal who are men in their
biology
they succeeded because they empowered
their feminine steve jobs creativity or
appreciation of beauty or empathy for
the user needs that's what made him
steve jobs
being obnoxious and annoying that's what
took away from it the masculine side
and it's about time that the world wakes
up to this when we raise the machines by
the way going back to scary smart are we
going to raise them to be masculine
geeks
or are we going to raise them to be
life-giving
i think really this is the biggest
failure ever
for me and i think for all of our
society
oh [ __ ]
that was really powerful
and it's so true and you know what i was
thinking that whole time my my
girlfriend is in bali at the moment and
she's been talking to me extensively
about
being more in touch with the feminine
and what they call you know yin which is
you know the absolutely yin and yang
energy so
um it all rang very very true and i
think you really helped me make sense of
all that in a very again relatable
understandable way
and i'm gonna um i'm gonna ask you to
carry on this tradition by writing a
question into the diary which will be
shown to my next guest but it will
remain a secret until then listen i
can't thank you enough you know um
sometimes i thank people for the time
um i think i want to thank you for
the lessons that you've taught me in
this conversation that will really make
my life a lot better and you know the
thing is as well is i i sit here every
week imparting what i know
so long after you walk out of the store
because you've left me with those
lessons i'm gonna spend the rest of my
life on this podcast talking about them
great as i do and also talking about
your book right so there's a couple of
guests that i encounter and i just spend
the next
ten years of my life just battling on
thank you and you're one of those really
really profound people and i understand
we said this before we started filming
but my manager don murray when he
started on like the first week of his
job here and i he started learning about
the podcast he said to me he said you've
got to get this guy called moen he's a
google x and i was like i don't you know
just i was like
you're the man i'm grateful and he kept
saying it and then
and then it wasn't just him and this is
where it got really sort of reinforced
other people were coming on the podcast
telling
me that i had to get you on over and
over again and you hear that you hear
this name three four five times you
think [ __ ] okay there's something
that i need to you know there's
definitely something i need to do and
then you know
someone in our team said oh who's in
london yeah so we we had to reach out
and i'm so deeply grateful for that i'm
grateful that you did i am really
grateful for the time that you gave me
and the opportunity to share some of
what i
am pondering it might it's not right but
it's really worth thinking about
great thing you're doing for the world
by sharing that honestly i don't say
this i'm not i don't gass my guests up
like this but it is really of tremendous
value and you know just i want to thank
you from the bottom of my heart thank
you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you